are you excited for injustice to bullets
launch is less than a month away and one
of the superhero fighting games
characters has been leaked ahead of
their announcement I'm Matt and this
GameSpot news update just wants to put a
smile on your face developer NetherRealm
is going to announce injustice twos next
character on April 28th and it seems
like that's going to be the Joker a
leaked gameplay video shows a match
between him and the flash but the person
behind the controller isn't very good at
the game it's actually kind of
frustrating especially when the Joker
pulls off his super move and we don't
even get to enjoy it because the flash
only had a sliver of health left at
least it's in French and we get to hear
what Lajoie core francais sounds like
that's actually pretty funny anyway
we'll report back when an official
announcement and gameplay video is
revealed so make sure to hit those like
and subscribe buttons injustice 2
launches for ps4 and Xbox one on may
16th with the new edition of The Joker
the fighting games roster has moved up
to 28 characters and according to the
injustice 2 website there are 10 more to
be revealed however I'm betting one of
those is pre-order bonus Darkseid and at
least a good chunk of them will come
with the season pass we'll keep you
updated as more is revealed but in the
meantime head on over to our Channel and
check out the official breakdowns for
poison ivy and Catwoman